Welcome to yang speaks the awesome Casa Murshid Hey, Costa.
M how are you?
I'm good, Andrew, how are you? Good to see you.
It's good to see you too. So I feel like you and I had a bunch in common, where,
uh, are you an immigrant or the son of immigrants? Uh.
Immigrant I'm an immigrant. I was born.
You were four accounts man accounts. I mean, uh, you must remember, uh,
arriving here. Um,
but the other thing we have in common is that we both have a legal background,
uh, though you became a civil rights lawyer, um,
and a community activist. Uh,
whereas I did something much more soul sucking for five months.
Yeah, I did the corporate, I did the corporate law thing for a couple of years,
uh, because you know, you need the paycheck to pay your student loans,
but you're right. It can be soul sucking if it's not the right fit for you.
And that's what helped me make the ultimate jump to civil rights and human
rights work. Full-time.
Yeah.
So tell us a little bit more about the civil rights legal work that you did over
that period of years,
because you'd built like a very strong following on the basis of fighting for
people.
Yeah. You know,
I think a lot of it goes back to what my parents ingrained and my siblings and I
had a very young age. So whatever you do in life,
if you're not centering service to humanity, it's really a waste of your life.
And that was the word that they used. And so, as I got older,
that was the lens with which how I looked at everything and going to law school
really opened my eyes to kind of understanding the incredible role the law
plays in whether people have basic access to decency and dignity or not.
And, uh, in law school, I got involved with a nonprofit here in Virginia, uh,
called the Virginia poverty law center,
their office of domestic and sexual violence.
And so started from a very early appointment, legal career,
supporting women who are survivors and that's pro bono work.
I do through this day. Um, I started working with, uh,
nonprofits on expanding healthcare and education and access and disaster relief
was a prison chaplain. And you know, all of this to say that, um,
when you get to understand how folks are struggling on the front lines,
you really begin to understand that, you know,
on the theme of you and I having a lot in common, Andrew,
you really begin to understand that these aren't Republican or Democrat issues,
these are basic human issues,
and it's critical that we stand together and work together and address these.
Um,
one of the most rewarding jobs I had was that a women's rights organization in
DC, where we were able to work with the department of justice and other various
government entities,
and just ensuring and advising that the policies being put before really do
give people equal access under the law. That's really what this has to be about.
Yeah, you're a humanist and humanitarian first and foremost,
I feel it's one reason I like you is that, um, you,
you have a very elevated perspective on a lot of these issues.
You're running in a relatively rural part of Virginia. Um,
that's been somewhat Republican leaning, but it's going purple right now.
And I think we've got a great chance to weigh in.
I think you're going to have a lot of wind at your back. Uh,
can you tell us a little bit more about your opponent, um,
and your district and the race, the state of the race,
how is costume race shaping up?
Well? So the reason is going great.
Let me start with my appointed career politician.
He's been in office 34 years and, uh, you know,
pretty heavily corporate funded. Uh,
hasn't really made the most kosher decisions financially bought himself stock in
a pharmaceutical company, working on COVID-19 treatment way back in February,
and then told us the virus has low-risk and not spreading. And, you know,
his entire approach, his entire campaign has been to attack me for my faith,
tied up me to Islamic terrorism and just all sorts of ridiculous things.
That's never been my style and we're not going to respond in kind. Um,
this is a district, uh, you know, if you visit Virginia,
you get to really see Southern hospitality.
And this is a district where people really, uh,
enjoy being in each other's company. They enjoy, uh, you know,
talking to complete strangers and there's this sense of civility. And,
and I think honor and dignity, and the folks here that I've seen,
where even if you are from a different perspective or different faith or
informational background, you're treated with a lot of respect.
And I've really enjoyed that about living in Virginia and raising our children
here. Um, the race has been going extraordinarily well. Uh,
and the early voter turnout, um, shows us with, uh, a massive lead, uh,
about 136,000 votes have been cast so far.
And we're looking at the polling that we've done on people who've already voted
right now. We are getting over 70% of the vote. And so for us,
it's about, you know, continuing that, uh,
that trend pushing folks to the polls,
making sure we're winning the folks on the fence. And, uh,
we're having event after event where now, uh,
Republicans and Trump supporters are showing up and we're welcoming them in.
And it's been a really powerful experience so far.
Um, I have the same experience on the travel costs.
Some where I would show up places where there were frankly not like that many
Asian Americans, uh, um, in some of the early States,
but people will listen to you. Uh,
they realize if you're there for the right reasons, um,
people just want to be respected and heard. And if you respect and hear them,
then they'll respect and hear you. And then they'll figure out, it's like,
wait a minute. This person actually, uh, here's my experience. It's like, they,
they, they spent some time with you and they realized that there are only two
possibilities,
one that you're an absolute crazy person or two that you're
genuinely there to help. And then when they get rid of number one, they're like,
wait, this person is actually sincere. And that's, that's very,
very powerful stuff. Like, you know,
it can draw in people from both sides of the aisle because
Americans in my mind are unified and being fed up right now. Uh, you know,
and they're like different strains of, uh, fed up in this, but the,
the fed up-ness is near universal. And if you seem like a genuine,
um, public and humanness to wants to help them in their families,
they'll support you.
Well. And we saw that yesterday, we had an event, uh, here in the district,
which about 30 people showed up not a massive event, but certainly not tiny.
It was a good, good crowd. And we had a big Rashid for Congress sign behind me.
It's the folks who are Trump supporters trying to drive in by Follichin,
you know, Trump 2020 with the Trump flags. And, and, you know, we ignored that.
And then whole bunch of them showed up carrying a Trump flag, uh,
and just kind of yelling and screaming.
And I paused the event and I had the microphone.
So I kind of raised my voice to the Trump supporters. And I was like, Hey guys,
you don't need to yell. You can be part of this conversation too.
Why don't you come on in?
And I think I caught them off guard because I think they expected me to kind of
shout them out, come on in, let's have a conversation. Uh, I got their name.
One of the guy's name was Chad.
And we actually had a pretty meaningful conversation. Um, you know,
I refused to respond to the vitriol,
but at the end of the day after the event ended Andrew out of these 30 people,
five of them walk up to me one by one and said, I'm a left love Republican.
I have never voted Democrat in my entire life.
I feel like I don't really have a party. I wasn't sure where to vote.
But now after seeing the way you treat people, even if they disagree with you,
you've got my vote. And I'm like, that's brilliant because that's exactly.
There are so many people who feel politically adrift right now,
because if you're a lifelong Republican and you look up at Donald Trump and you
say, this is not what I signed up for. You know,
I voted for this guy last time and like,
this has been a crushing disappointment. And, uh, uh,
so then they're looking around and saying, what do I do? And, you know,
you presented the right kind of unifying figure and message for them to say,
like, he's sincere, he wants to help. Uh, so costs,
you are forecast relief. Like after you get to Congress,
when's the first time you were exposed to universal basic income. Uh,
like when did you first hear that?
You know, so I'm a student of history and, uh,
there was a great book by Michael Hart, uh, called the 100 where he, uh,
ranks a hundred, most influential people in history. Um,
it's a great way to sound really smart by only reading like a five page X on
every major figure in history and, and a number of 52,
uh, was, uh, or is he ranks a person in, uh, Homer who was a second caliph,
uh, after prophet Muhammad and Omer was not just a religious figure,
but he was an economic genius.
And he introduced this concept UBI about 1400 years ago, uh,
to the, you know,
the Arabian peninsula and to the Islamic empire at that time.
And it was designed to be exactly that, you know,
a guaranteed form of cash payments to working families,
to ensure that they could have a basic level of,
of livelihood and it helped ignite the economy.
And that's actually why Michael Hart by Dr. Michael Hart ranks him as number 52
because of his economic genius. And that was one of them. So for me,
this principle is something that I was to be exposed at an early age and in my
research and study,
not only was I excited to find out that we were close to passing UBI in the
United States, back in the seventies, under a Republican president, no less.
But if you look at all the studies around the world, uh,
you find consistent study after study demonstrating that this not only uplifts
people out of poverty, but it ignites the economy. It,
it advances entrepreneurship and innovation. It creates upward mobility.
It decreases rates of suicide and depression and mental illness and elevates
senses of well-being and just the overall human experience.
So I see every reason to push forward for this.
Haven't seen a single valid reason to oppose it.
Yes.
And you're exactly the person who's going to help us pass this thing when we get
you into Congress and we'll all be around and say, well, no, what,
what do we do to restore a path forward for millions of Americans,
but also to reconstitute a sense of public trust and I've run organizations.
And it's very hard to just go around asking people to,
for their buy-in or their trust or their confidence,
unless you actually step forward yourself and invest in them. Like if we,
as a society say, look, everyone has intrinsic value.
Your kids have value you matter. Uh,
and we're not just going to you and talk about it.
Like we're actually going to put our money where our mouth is like,
that is actually the, the transformative, uh,
change that people will respond to because they're just people talking to
them and not doing anything.
And then if you actually do something that meaningfully impacts and improves
their life, then it's a game changer and we can make it happen.
Like you're going to be one of the people that helps make it happen from the
halls of Congress starting 20, 21, after you win this thing after you win,
um, what district are you in, in Virginia?
And if someone wants to help you and support your campaign, where do they go?
How do they help?
We're the first district of Virginia. You can go to our website, uh,
receipt for va.com. I'm on social media at cost and receipt.
That's my name really, really easy to find. And to add to your point, I mean,
there's a reason Andrew, there are campaigns.
Logan has compassion through action that having compassion in and of itself,
isn't enough. You need to take action.
Otherwise it's just a meaningless word that makes you feel good,
but doesn't actually do anything.
And so we need to elevate the level of love and compassion that we have for
humanity into meaningful action,
to get them the support that they need and deserve the basic human dignity,
food, water, and shelter, healthcare, education, and clothing. Um,
and for those who want to get involved in our kind of a campaign,
I don't care what side of the political aisle you are on.
If these values matter to you, check us out and receipt for ba.com,
send us an email to organizing@receiptforva.com. And we will get you on board.
Yes, they will get you on board. Uh, I love it. Uh,
and you're, you're beyond a humanist and human humanitarian.
You're like a grandeur. And I love to do our part because you're right. Um,
the only thing that makes me feel better about a problem is doing something out
it, uh, and we just need more Americans to have that same, uh,
approach because things suck right now. But if we all did something about it,
uh, we could improve things pretty quickly. And one thing you can do,
that's very straightforward is help candidates.
Like COSAM get into Congress where they can actually S uh, pushing, uh,
the laws of the land in the right direction. Thank you costs. Um, really, man,
I feel great about your race. I think there's going to be a very powerful, uh,
wind at your back. That's going to help blow you
forward across this metaphorical finish line. Um, and, uh,
you're just getting started. It's awesome. Thank you, man. Good to be here.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.